representa los siguientes datos usando
un diagrama de caja excluye la mediana
cuando calculé los cuartiles y bueno nos
dan un montón de datos y después dicen
si te sirve de algo puedes arrastrar los
números y colocarlos en un orden
distinto y de hecho eso nos va a servir
bastante el orden no afecta la respuesta
te encargo que hagas algunos ejercicios
por tu cuenta pero hagamos este
ejercicio como un ejemplo lo primero que
se me ocurre es que si voy a hacer un
diagrama de caja entonces va a ser mucho
mejor se ordenó estos números así que
ordenemos estos números de menor a mayor
y para eso date cuenta que el más
pequeño de todos es el 3 lo voy a jalar
para acá y lo voy a poner aquí después
por aquí tengo un 4 lo voy a poner aquí
un 5 otro 5 otro 5 y bueno date cuenta
que no tenemos 6 pero si tenemos 7 no
voy a poner aquí otros 7 por acá y aquí
hay otros otros siete en 888
8 10 y 11 de tal manera que si ya lo
tenemos ordenados de menor a mayor y
bueno ya con esto podemos graficar los
bigotes porque ya tenemos nuestro rango
mi número menor estrés y mi número mayor
es 11 es por esto que los bigotes me
ayudan a visualizar el rango así que
vamos a ponerlo mi número menor es 3
mientras que mis números mayores 11 de
lugo y ahora vamos a ver cuál es la
mediana de mi conjunto la mediana de mi
conjunto va a ser y bueno para eso
veamos tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 y 14 de datos así que como tenemos un
número par de datos vamos a fijarnos en
los números que tenemos en la mitad y
justo por ahí voy a encontrar mi mediana
porque no tenemos solo un número en
medio no puedo decir que este 7 es mi
mediana porque tengo
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 datos de este lado
mientras que tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 datos de
este lado y de igual manera para este 7
por lo tanto como no tengo solo un
número en medio la mediana debe estar
bueno entre 1 2 3 4 5 o 6 entre este y
este dato y si te das cuenta son iguales
por lo tanto ya sabemos que nuestra
mediana debe de ser 7 es decir en medio
de ellos 2 así que si tienes un número
par de datos debes fijarte en los dos
números que quedan a la mitad y tomar la
media de ellos y bueno la media entre 7
y 7 eso es muy sencillo va a ser 7 así
que ese dato será la mediana del
conjunto total 7 por lo tanto no voy a
poner con esta línea justo aquí y ahora
busquemos la mediana de la mitad
inferior de los números y también de la
mitad superior de los números y aquí
dice que excluyamos la mediana cuando
calculemos
cuartil es por lo tanto vamos a hacerlo
pero en este caso mi mediana es 7 el
número que estaba entre 7 y 7 por lo
tanto como nos fijamos en el número que
estaba en medio de estos dos entonces
vamos a tomar 7 datos primero para
fijarnos en nuestra mitad inferior y ahí
busquemos la mediana el número de en
medio así que tomemos los primeros 7
números me quedaría 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 los
primeros 7 datos son estos y bueno el
que está en medio de ellos va a ser
aquel que tenga 3 a la derecha y 3 a la
izquierda es decir este que tenemos aquí
este 5 tiene 3 a la derecha y tiene 3 a
la izquierda para llegar al séptimo dato
entonces eso quiere decir que este 5 de
aquí va a darnos la mediana de mi mitad
inferior así que este será la frontera
izquierda de mi caja y ahora habrá que
buscar la frontera derecha y para eso
vamos a buscar el número de en medio
that superior de los números y empecemos
a buscar cuál es la mediana de ellos así
que en este caso tengo uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete números y la
mediana de la mitad superior va a ser el
número de en medio
va a ser que tenga tres a la derecha y
tres a la izquierda así que date cuenta
que es este ocho tiene 123 a derecha y
bueno tiene 123 a la izquierda para
llegar a este 7 es decir el 8 tiene 3
datos de ambos lados en la mitad
superior y por lo tanto este 8 es el que
nos da la frontera derecha de nuestra
caja así que vamos a poner esta línea de
aquí la voy a acomodar en el oro justo
por acá y si te das cuenta ya acabamos
lo hemos logrado hemos construido
nuestro diagrama de cajas y bigotes el
cual nos ayuda a visualizar el rango
entero y también la mediana de nuestros
números es hora de comprobar respuesta
y de lujo estamos bien